all righty let's jump right into it so
first question does SEO still matter in
2018 or can companies ignore it and
focus on other channels so this is a
question I get asked a lot and I've been
asked this question in many years past
and sometimes the quote the answer could
have been maybe but now I definitively
think that SEO absolutely matters and
won't matter even more and the primary
reason is companies were using other
channels to drive acquisition and
startups could start the company and
think of say PR or paid media they've
raised the money they use paid media to
generate buzz and generate new clients
but those channels have now gotten
significantly more expensive brand cpc's
on AdWords have gone up Facebook has
made it a lot harder to get a organic
reach and now you're paying for traffic
on Facebook PR in our world where we
want to measure everything it's not as
measurable and then what happens is
companies do spend a bunch of money on
those different channels there's they're
maximizing their paid budgets on google
they're maximizing their paid budgets on
Facebook they may even go into being and
say hey maybe I have some you know
potential market opportunity on bing and
then they're like what's next and what
they do is they look in their analytics
tools they're like all right we've got
break down the channels we've got a list
I wrecked traffic don't know anything
about that general what to do to get
more we have referral traffic those are
outbound deals some of those people link
to us some of those things we did
intentionally we have our pay Channel
great we know what we're doing they're
organic so this is an untapped Channel
we don't know how what we did we
followed some best practices we read SEO
for dummies we did what we thought was
right
driving business very very little
investment and then they think maybe if
we invest in it now we'll get so much
more and will intentionally be working
on this channel so I think that's where
we are in 2018 where like this is the
untapped channel this is the channel
which has been driving business for free
and now companies put effort in it it'll
actually generate significant returns
mmm and where should they get started
say they're at just like the bare
minimum you know they like have a little
bit of content maybe of a blog or
something but where should they really
focus their energy in the beginning it
really depends on the kind of company so
if it's an e-commerce company they
want to think about architecture and and
you know companies in any commerce
company thinking about SEO they should
have thought about SEO before they chose
their e-commerce platform so they want
to make sure the site is structured
properly to scale so what do you do if
like you get a new distributor and now
you're ready to add 10,000 products and
your website can't handle 10,000
products and now you're gonna load it up
and each URLs gonna be one two three
four five six seven next one is one two
three four five six eight so that's not
gonna scale for SEO you're not gonna
have any way of putting in your right
product descriptions and optimizing
against likely competitors that are
selling the same products so that's
e-commerce they should focus on good
architecture or should have focused on
good architecture long before media
that's kind of different that's where
they can look at what has worked for
them in the past and my favorite search
tool is is Google search console because
it it's from Google it may or may not be
as accurate as can be but it's probably
more accurate than other tools which are
sort of projecting what the actual truth
is using that tool they can see what's
working here's what we're getting
traffic on then Mary that data with
analytics like here's what's actually
performing and converting for us that's
where they should double down like build
more content there build more conversion
elements on that and expand mm-hm
who's doing it really well I think media
companies have actually gotten around to
doing this really well like the way they
cross link and just have every sort of
page possible so you take like an item
in the news today they've got all these
cross links to things they've written in
the past which suddenly can become
relevant to the searcher not it's not
newsworthy anymore but if someone
searches it like hey maybe they want to
hear about a cow that got struck by
lightning yeah four years ago and like
there's a display ad so I think media
has got around to like really maximizing
the value of their content when it comes
to e-commerce it's really only Amazon
that's doing it amazing Amazon has like
you know built a structure where every
single product and they have billions of
SKUs somehow is discovered by the search
engines and if you manage to put in the
right keywords that match that right
product you will find it and what are
the okay so let's like be a little bit
more specific so what are what are the
exact mechanisms they're using to
coverable so for the most important
thing when it comes to SEO and making
sure that your site is somewhat
optimized for SEO is that the site is
fully crawlable so no orphan pages so
amazon has built this structure where no
matter what the product is it may be
something that there's only two
customers in the world there that
product is somehow cross-linked if
Google drops their bot anywhere within
the site it will crawl the whole site
may take a long time but it will find
that page that's where anybody that
wants to do this right has to think
about like what is this thing that I'm
putting on whether it's an article or a
product like what is it related to to
make sure that there's a path for that
page to be found by I'm Bob and and
that's where Amazon's doing an amazing
job of making sure like ever there is a
taxonomy for every single page every
page is discovered and every page can it
can be ranked with right queries so in
the context of a company that's not an
e-commerce company would you recommend
you know using plugins to display
relevant content to link to other pages
or building your own like how would you
actually set up that architecture so for
media the article you can use a plug-in
because all you're trying to do is
create relevance yeah get links yeah if
users click it great if they don't click
it okay but like things should be built
for users okay when it comes to
e-commerce there has to be a good plug
in or something built internally because
it you're not going to want to have like
say a red sweater cross linked over to
like a dog leash yeah right so like
that's where a plug-in that sort of you
know correlates between hey red and
here's a red dog leash that's not going
to work so you might want to build
something internally again media like
what a lot of media companies do is
they're just sort of looking for
relationships one thing I found to be
very effective for its cross linking is
just randomization so if you randomize
your URLs you make sure that it provided
your your randomization algorithm is
correct every single URL ends up being
cross linked know if users click it
great if they don't end up clicking you
still have achieved that that level of
cross linking that Google can discover
it
so just literally random
pieces of content or products added in
their products not so much because it
there is a user experience to that when
it comes to articles it will work really
because like you know again someone's
reading some article they're reading
about you know something that you know
President Trump said today and there's
an article about you know somebody
getting struck by lightning they may
click it and it could be relevant and
you know who's to say that we shouldn't
that's not not a matter article that
might be interesting yeah oh I think
that will always be interesting
what about paying for links on other
sites that's it absolute no no according
to Google however people still do it
yeah and they're doing it through like a
business development relationship if
it's done purely just to get the SEO
link okay then it's not advisable
because you know someone could report
that to Google and you don't want to go
down that path of of buying links it
seems like there are so many of these
don't do these no knows what are what
are the other things people should
absolutely watch out for the big one is
is anything that you're not comfortable
talking about maybe to your mother so
like you know hiding text at the bottom
of the page so you're building a bunch
of content like you know if you're not
if it's not something you're gonna be
proud of that's probably something you
shouldn't do if it's something the way
Google really puts it if you're doing
exposed explicitly to rank for SEO then
that's probably something you shouldn't
do they have a bunch of rules around
that but really like there's nothing you
should be doing that's just for crawlers
okay should all be for users you know
maybe if there's some relevance for
hidden text on a page for users you
might have an explanation right okay and
then are there things that were maybe um
maybe quite useful in the past that are
no longer relevant like I'm thinking
like you know like meta keywords stuff
like that are there things that are kind
of just like no longer useful so meta
keywords is a great example of something
that's no longer useful and the reason
meta keywords existed is because Google
and other search engines actually were
relevant at the time didn't have a
really good way of understanding text so
now we're like in this stage of
development around search where Google
announced today that Google home
understands Spanish so like the
understanding spoken words and their
understanding spoke at where it's not
even in English
so you know they don't need you to put
meta keywords on a page to say where
you're trying to rank for but back then
when you know search was early
they kind of did Google was more
advanced in other search engines as they
were able to determine what the page is
about mm-hmm however like meta keywords
worst was still a signal of like maybe
what's on the page of course marketer
scan they spam that by putting like what
they thought would be the most relevant
words which were usually porn but yeah
that's what people were searching for
and what about actually so we obviously
this is on YouTube when YouTube asks for
keywords do you recommend people use
those I mean like we use them but to a
limited extent
so YouTube's different because Google's
not great at really understanding what
the video is about yeah so by giving
more information and it could it be a
transcription it's those keywords that
you put in you're giving a better
indication of what the video is about
with YouTube though it's really hard to
guarantee your ranking yeah so the more
information you can give the more likely
you have a chance at playing that game
one other place where keywords are
really important and they're hidden is
when you're trying to rank an app on the
App Store so one google the way they
rank an app is based on all the visible
text so it's that the name of the app
which is sort of like the title the
short description which is forget how
many characters but a shorter paid
description of the app which you see
right above the fold and then the long
description which is thousands of
characters or you just fill in whatever
you want so all of that goes into what
Google's gonna rank the app on Google
Play yeah on iOS there are P words and I
think you have a hundred characters
hidden so if you're trying to rank an
app on like you know let's say selling
something random but you think that
people are going to search form keywords
that's where you would hide it no one
would even know that's what you're
trying to rank on oh man okay gotcha
and so when it comes to actually like
building out your SEO like what is the
kind of content that's important because
you know we talk about a content
marketing we talked about in podcast
before we've talked about it in the
context of YC and other companies and
oftentimes people just kind of copy what
other companies are doing and you know
it's not always the most effective
strategy so
how do you frame like what's the most
important content to be actually working
on for your company whatever that might
be so content something that people have
talked about forever and like the
headers think content is king and they
used it for like you said content
marketing but really that's it's a
something that we always need to
underscore when it comes to SEO is
because people stop using content if you
fill up a page with images or video or
JavaScript you'd no longer have content
so Google as much as they say they're
really good at understanding and ranking
JavaScript they're not because in real
time when they're looking for your
content you are handicapping yourself by
not having just raw text words on the
page so when it comes to like SEO
content raw text words on a page so and
you know it's it's not really a truism
the more that more is better but it is
sort of because if you have a product
description and you only have a hundred
words and that somebody else has the
same product but they have a thousand
words in different ways of describing
the product more than likely they will
get more search traffic because as
people search different keywords related
to they become relevant because they've
used the words and you're not relevant
because you have not used the words so
in that sense more keywords are better
more keyword or more words are better
more words are not better if all you're
doing is filling up that words with
emptiness like if you're describing you
know aim a mug and you describe many
different ways like this is a mug that
is a cup that you can drink or you can
you know pour things in and there's all
these irrelevant keywords that's sort of
a waste of time and it won't convert for
you because users are gonna read that
they're gonna realize they're just gonna
be super confused but if that's where
people add in like reviews and that sort
of thing for e-commerce so reviews can
be tough too because Google can
understand that it's it's user generated
reviews and it may not be as high
quality but that's something where like
I don't know it those are one of those
things where you have to take that
question and test it from an SEO
standpoint like if I had reviews on to
this am I gonna rank more on different
keywords and get more traffic or as
Google gonna look at that says
user-generated and not send more traffic
for the content that's in the review
gotcha okay so then what about you know
your your consumer company it's not an
e-commerce company and you want to get
into generating content that will
right traffic for you where do you start
and then like let's go through the
actual workflow so let's think of an
example company they're selling a
service so you want to come up with
anything related to that service and the
content is two the first kind of content
you're gonna need is is the closest to
that service let's say the services is
plumbing you just go old fashioned your
plumber so you offer different services
that people need like on clogging drains
so you want to have a piece of content
that talks about unclogging drinks now
when people search and this is something
where you don't really need to rank on
unclog drains anymore because google is
very local so if you're in San Francisco
and you're a plumber and someone
searches unclog drains you now have a
much higher chance of ranking on unclog
drains than roto-rooter hmm was just
national by adding your you don't dress
your guests your dress should be there
and you there will be you need to have
some sort of local Signia but Google's
going to show for owned clogged drains
that's a need yeah a plumbing need right
now Google doesn't help to even show
someone not in your area okay so you
want to have that piece of content
now as you build out that content you
can move further up the buying funnel
which is right now I'm an immediate
problem under clogged drains but how do
I make sure I never have a clogged drain
making have best practices and how to
maintain your plumbing so as you build
out this fuller site it can even go into
like how do you hire someone to renovate
your house and make sure you have
quality plumbing and what's the kind of
piping you should choose and let's say
you're going to buy it yourself where
should you buy it so there's many many
different avenues of content all related
to your original service which helped
which can help you establish yourself as
an expert in yeah I mean and pipes and
clogged drains but how are you actually
so I if the angle is like it's just
taste like it's just opinion and you
figure out like if you really understand
your customer you can know all these
things but is there a more programmatic
way to be like okay customers that end
up on our site are looking for XYZ thing
how do you find out those terms those
queries so you won't know until you
start so the best way is you're using
Google search console you can see the
kinds of things people are looking for
if you don't have that content so say
you've had a great piece of content on
clogged drains but everyone searching
about like on a clogged bathroom sink
like that's the specific thing they're
looking for and you don't have a piece
of content on unclog bathroom sink yeah
time to write that piece of content now
before you start what you can do is you
can go to the Google Keyword tool I
think that it's a called geek Google
Keyword planner now they keep changing
so if you're the Google Keyword planner
and you're searching for keywords
related to what you need so you're
looking for drains you're looking for
clogs you're looking for unclog and that
should give you a bunch of ideas along
with search volume about what people are
looking for you can also use my favorite
su paid SEO tool which is called a H
refs they also have a keyword tool so
you're getting ideas and from there you
want to sort of battle test those ideas
by launching them and seeing what kind
of traffic comes in seeing how it
performs like maybe you have this great
page on unclogging drains and all people
do is learn and never fill out a lead or
never call your phone number and are you
tracking that through Google Analytics
you're using other tools what do you
recommend analytics would be my favorite
tool for tracking how their performance
is going on like as far as traffic
coming in yeah so even though you can't
see the keywords people are searching on
analytics you can see the URLs so you
look at the URL that's generating
traffic you see the conversions
hopefully you've tagged your goals and
analytics and you see the conversions
that come through and you know what's
your best performing content now you can
take that same URL put into the Google
search console and then see the kinds of
keywords you're even getting impressions
on if their keywords are getting
impressions on but people aren't
clicking that's an area of optimization
if your keywords that you're getting
impressions on people are clicking but
not converting another area of
optimization so it's very iterative like
you're starting with getting ideas maybe
starting with keywords building it and
then learning from the planning from
what you're getting so so you said that
it's important to have raw text on the
page that's the easiest to parse for you
know Google and now there are things
that are crawling your site how to
images affect all this and are they
important at all so the most important
thing to consider with in all SEO is
that your you're doing this for users
yeah you're doing this because users are
going to use Google
then find your website on Google and
then click through into your website and
then hopefully experience your website
and do whatever you want them to do
whether you're generating revenue from
ad impressions you want them to click
another page if you're generating leads
you want them felt the lead for them if
you are selling a product you want them
to buy it or whatever that is so images
help with that user experience so all
you're doing is build putting text on
the page none of us like to look at raw
walls of text so the images in that
sense should fit in with their user
experience but there is an SEO aspect to
that and that is people like Google
images is one of the largest if you want
to think about it as a separate search
engine it's one of the largest search
engine after Google mm-hmm I think
YouTube is number two but Google images
is definitely up there so if you put
images on the page one thing you can do
is make sure the images are titled so
the actual JPEG file or PNG file are
tagged with the keyword so say it's
you're selling coffee mugs you want to
call it like coffee mugs JPEG and not
just some random - the file name that
came from the camera mm-hmm you also
want to put alt tags or alt text around
the actual image which is still needed
in today's day but Google eventually
will figure out what images are like yes
figure out images are alt text is the
version of meta keywords like meta
keywords used to be so Google didn't
know or doesn't know what the images are
so you're saying with images yeah and
that helps you rank the actual ranking
formula for Google images is really
really hard to discern but if you follow
best practices like you have this chance
of you know people searching and then
there's this additional avenue of people
finding content yeah well it seems like
Pinterest is been the one who unlocked
that right like if many things I search
for and I click through I end up on
Pinterest and I'm forced to login so
that's essentially them doing a great
job of SEO around the images and then
they have these unique images and they
show up on on Google however there is
something interesting about your
Pinterest question which is Google
specifically does not like search within
search Google would much prefer that you
don't go to Pinterest that you go
directly to where that image
but maybe that site didn't do a great
job of optimizing the image but
Pinterest did
so now Pinterest is that layer in
between mm-hmm so if you just sort of
follow best practices like Pinterest
does now you're skipping it the
middleman and they're coming directly it
is there are there best practices around
you know like technical aspects like
literal resolution of the image anything
like that not as far as I know okay it's
really raw and sort of like put your alt
text in you could put a title and around
the image and caption it yeah just give
there's other there's also relevancy so
like the kind of page that they mention
saan sort of gives more signals but for
now I don't know that Google is really
looking into the quality of the image
and they're not yet I don't think
throughout a place but their
understanding with images and then
choosing to rank it gotcha okay and so
say all right so now we've built out our
content site or keep with like San
Francisco plumbing and we've made you
know 20 blog posts about whatever we
think someone might be searching for
when it comes to distribution are there
any like non-intuitive Pro tips that you
would recommend like are you suggesting
people start getting paid traffic
through their sites or or do they just
leave them up and hope for organic you
can't hope for organic you can wait like
years for the organic traffic to show
you need to be proactive about that
however in the meantime and yeah
actually like when you your organic
strategy should start when you put up
the website so in the meantime you can
be generating paid traffic and then
organic has time to grow into a until
organic becomes an important channel for
you the we're sharing things on Facebook
or you know sharing things even with
with friends and family helps is that if
you've created create content let's say
again on the San Francisco plumbing
you've created the best guide in the
world about how to unclog your drains
and you share that on Facebook now other
people may share that too on the you
know to their friends and people see
that and then someone out there is going
to decide that you know they're writing
a blog about Do It Yourself and they
just have to link and recommend this
blog post that you've written or article
that you've written about on clogging
drains and that's how you're getting
links and you're starting the
distribution of that for again
and from there google discovers it you
can also go and like it you know as you
build your website so you know it's a
service website get yourself listed on
all the directories so you know Chamber
of Commerce and other directories for
your neighborhood so it the directories
don't really give links but they give
avenues for discovery and then as you
get discovery you can generate links so
a pretty common question and word around
SEO is links link building all that kind
of stuff is it important and if so how
would you how would you go about doing
it so links are what differentiate go
when Google first came out so at the
time there was Yahoo and a bunch of
other crawlers and indexers and search
engines if you want to call them that
and what Google did differently is they
ranked a site based on the quality of
the links and it was sort of academic
like if you were an academic and you've
come out with something interesting
other academics are we're going to set
you so Google determined that if you
were and they had this PageRank patent
and algorithm that if you were quality
and other people other websites would
link to you so that that was how Google
sort of grew into that and then of
course people spammed it they bought
links and they you know they did a bunch
of spammy things to get links and traded
links and all that links are still very
important but they're not important in
the sense they used to be where people
measure them by quantity like my
competitor has a hundred links to this
page I need 101 links and if I get 101
links that I will guarantee you rank
ahead of them so that doesn't work
anymore what you need are a quality and
relevant links and it could only be a
handful of links and that's all you need
and what Google's doing is this is the
algorithm borrowing a sort of link
equity from the pages that link to you
you can make your page more valuable and
relevant for all the other queries that
people might find you so it doesn't have
to be like this page say it stanford is
talking about metaphysics and you're
talking about plumbing therefore you can
only rank on metaphysics because
metaphysics is linking right but like
that link value is helping you rank
better on plumbing because if stanford
thinks you're a good plumber you might
be a good plumber right now where I like
to do link building and where it's the
most effective is to create interesting
content and this is sort of where SEO
goes hand-in-hand with PR it's you're
creating interesting content that people
might want to talk about
and then from there people might also
want to link to it and one good metric
of measuring if you're on par is two
people share about it on Facebook what
do they like it because if they the
motivation to like something is the same
as the motivation to Lincoln mm
something one if you have a website so
the most successful link building
campaign I ever did wasn't even really
an intentional link building campaign
was I when I was living in Singapore I
did a survey with a company or an agency
that measured the cleanliness and
satisfaction of people around bathrooms
and I heard called the restroom
Association of Singapore and we created
this survey and I created a bunch of
interesting questions around people's
bathroom habits which something people
are always interested in and from that
survey I turned it into an infographic
and a blog post and then just kind of
put it out there and I basically got
links from every single media site
within English media site within
Southeast Asia and even got translated
into other languages and that just that
was like but like they were mentioning
it and they were just providing due
credit back to the original source with
a link so if you're doing creative
things and you're doing good PR that's
sort of like a good SEO effort because
you're getting that link to that content
how many links you need still we
wouldn't know where do those links need
to come from like that you know you
can't know but if you're you're working
on these processes in making sure each
page is linked you're doing what's
necessary to get that link value into
each page mmm and are you spending time
and energy and money on PR itself or do
you just mean like hopefully organic
traffic yeah so I'm thinking of this is
like PR mindedness rather than actual
PRI from my experience the PR people
I've worked with they don't necessarily
do things for SEO so I've even worked
the PR agency where like they were proud
of a article that showed up and or a an
article that was in print and he gave me
the PDF that did nothing for SEO
obviously I mean they just yeah yeah but
if they're doing something weirds action
an actual link over a mention with like
here's a credit back to the source that
would be a link and that would be
valuable for us yeah okay and then as a
as an individual like thought leader a
type person thinking
about link-building do you recommend
people go out and like you know blog on
other sites is it is that still an
effective strategy it is an effective
strategy as long as it's not spammy and
I got an accidental sort of link
probably best link I ever got to my blog
is I was working with a professor at
Stanford he invited me to his class an
interesting seminar not passionate about
things related
there's an interesting seminar and he
asked me to do him a favor and take
notes and I got this idea that if I took
notes maybe I could turn it into a blog
post and if I turn it into a blog post
maybe he'll publish it and I you know
asked him if that would that was
something he'd be interested in doing
and he did and now I have a blog post on
Stanford's website linking back to my
personal blog so that is a guest post
but there's nothing spammy about that
like this was content the professor
needed and that's something that can be
repeated anywhere professors are like
anybody they can meet baited in with by
their egos and you can write content
about them and they're very likely would
link from their third classroom web
pages well also if you just make
something good like this is this is
something that is overlooked time and
time and time again it's like make
something good yeah that is the
underlying fate of ingredient anything
related SEO okay good content will get
good likes yeah perfect
and so how much time do you give
yourself to to really test an idea and
test to see that something's working it
depends on the scale of idea so when it
comes to a piece of content and the
website's brand new could you have a
really really long time to know if that
contents resonating to get ideas around
it how many year does that what does
that mean it could be a year okay but if
like you know it's a going concern say
you know it's a it's y combinator you've
already got a ton of traffic you know
that you put something up it's instantly
going get found people are gonna search
for it that could happen in a matter of
weeks mm-hmm okay and what about the all
this in the context of mobile like I
know the habits are very different so
there's a lot of talk about mobile first
and Google moving to mobile first mm-hm
and within that what people forget is
that there's still only 24 hours in a
day so yes we are we're on our mobile
devices all of our waking hours but
eight of those waking hours or
or those you know the more than eight of
those waking hours were actually at a
desktop or laptop so we're on a larger
device so it's not that we shouldn't
optimize for the desktop anymore it's
just that you need to consider mobile
and need to consider user behavior there
are many many products that are probably
never going to be bought on mobile like
probably no one's gonna buy enterprise
software on a mobile device and I highly
doubt at least in our first world
economy people are going to book their
entire vacation on a mobile device you
know probably like you know do a little
searching and you're you know while
you're sitting on the train where should
I go what should I see but like before
you shell out thousands of dollars
there's a desktop involved or you know
if you're doing let's say Black Friday
shopping
you may read some emails around things
around Black Friday deals you may do
some searching on your phone but before
you go and buy like a brand new TV
you're gonna go to a desktop site look
at that and you look at it as many
images as you can read reviews possibly
even purchase it on the desktop so yes
Mobile is growing we need to take it we
need to you know consider mobile users
but not at the expense of desktop users
so with that in mind what are the what
are the best practices to account for
both when it comes to SEO not much it's
really taken to account that there's a
smaller screen and people are clicking
through on search from a smaller screen
and then the biggest thing that you
really need to keep in mind is that it's
not about ranking in the top ten results
you actually have to rank in the top
three results and you just try harder
because of mobile devices you know
there's just less results yeah I mean
that that does seem to be the permit
challenge right like getting from the
second page to the first page and then
to the top of the page do you have any
mean obviously like you've written about
this pretty extensively online but like
what are your pro tips so rates really
matching user intent so as we discussed
like the user is the most important so
understanding the user and getting in
the users head and finding the queries
that the user will search for to find
your content so it's not about like what
do I need to do to be in the first page
because that's like a very vague goal
you want to be in the first page for
what your specialty is no our plumber
specialty is unclogging drains that are
very old
so they that only matters and they can
chart and let's say that plumber can
charge a lot of money for their
specialty so that's what they want to be
in the first page for write a lot of
content for that specialty make sure
they're found on mobile devices and the
first couple results on the desktop and
for sure the first couple results but
just generally ranking for like this
broad term that's very hard to do and if
you're not a big brand may even be a
brand if you can't spend against it like
a lot of cash yes
and in the the international context how
do you think about getting getting to
that for assuming that you have a clear
intent say you're you're gonna franchise
your San Francisco plumbing business is
going to open up in Beijing what should
you be thinking about so international
is the untapped opportunity in SEO but
it will probably remain untapped for a
long time because the products and
services most American centric or
English centric websites offer aren't
necessarily relevant for a global
audience you can take a couple steps
into becoming relevant so say you're
your ecommerce if you partner with a
company that can enable shipping other
countries so you don't actually need to
do the shipping yourself you just need a
mate get yourself listed or make
whatever integration you need necessary
in order to get things out to other
countries if customers want to buy at
least you've enabled that you can also
take other sort of payment like work
with a payment provider that may be able
to take other currencies it may come
into you as dollars but you just want to
work with that gateway that can take the
pound or take the URL because if you're
just working with a standard payment
gateway like if someone doesn't have a
US credit card they there are they can
advance okay so that's an opportunity
just to expand a little bit maybe if you
have an audience in another country
that's where you can take a one step
forward into SEO where say you have that
audience in Beijing you might want to
create one page about your product in
Chinese and then people will discover it
click through and that's an experiment
I've tried in the past where like you
localize a page you have your CTAs in
that local language click the CTA and
then bang you in English mm-hmm so
you're obviously you kind of filter out
a lot of people but you're also going to
get people through that where you know
if they may be a potential you know
customer of your product they would
still go through that funnel
so you've brought into your appeal
you've broadened your potential base by
having your content translated and you
can potentially get more customers at
the bottom of the funnel all right yeah
in general international huge
opportunity but probably not relevant
for most companies hmm okay and so let's
use YC as an example right all of our
content is in English it's at Y
Combinator comm right do you build
another website with a separate
top-level domain or do you add you know
Chinese translated content to your main
blog what do you do so you used to be
best practices where you would build
another website for customers in another
country I no longer think that's the
best practice okay and the reason I've
tested this a few times and the the
reason behind that best practice is that
users trust something local more so a UK
users going to trusted code at UK Google
actually hides URLs in search to begin
with and you can't in you know they test
it sometimes it comes in sometimes comes
out on mobile you don't see the URL at
all so that doesn't matter users don't
even know that you're calm versus coda
UK so with that in mind you have a great
website already why would you split your
efforts and create a new website so what
you're going to do is you just want to
open up a new directory that's very
explicitly another language and you want
to follow the two letter naming
convention or the three letter naming
convention so Google understands exactly
what it is so if you're going to Chinese
I think it would be as eh for Chinese
you're going it were a few go in another
country so obviously the UK would be UK
or GB mm-hmm so Google understands that
localization aspect of like hey this is
hard to get it somewhere else
mm-hmm you wouldn't want to go to like
you know say Spanish and just you know
do SP aan yeah this would be hard for
Google understand and with that you're
doing a direct a subdirectory not a
subdomain hmm okay and then you are just
having your content machine translated
are you paying for translators what are
you doing again user centric if content
is machine translated the machines have
to be very very good yeah if it's very
good and it's not that important
content then that should probably work
if you really want to get users through
funnel and you want to make sure there's
no misunderstandings you should hire
local people to translate for you okay
so you know in the context let's so we
can just use YC as an example is pretty
easy you would just take say like our
top 100 blog posts pay for a translator
who's like native in Chinese or Spanish
or whatever it might be post it on the
act of Y Combinator comm site in a new
subdirectory dedicated just for Chinese
right okay and then meaning like a new
sub domain on the blog not so bit mean
directory within the blog right okay and
link that through the nav on the blog
what what is the best practice there so
you could do it through the nav on the
blog but a may confuse your existing
English users what most people would do
is have some sort of language selector
at the top or the bottom of the page
mmm-hmm again with the user mind and the
language selector should be an HTML link
which switches over to that new
directory mm-hmm what you don't want
that to be is a JavaScript link where it
sort of reloads the page and brings up
the new content because and Google
possibly couldn't follow it hmm okay and
so all the content is actually there all
the content well so all the content
you've translated is there right so you
don't want to have Dart like any sort of
automated like I change I'm changing
let's say en to automatically CH or
something okay gotcha
and then in terms of appearing on
separate search engines in across
multiple languages what are the best
practices for that so there really are
no other important search engines in the
world there's I mean they're locally
specific so there's Baidu for Chinese so
if you care about China
then it's Baidu if you care about Korea
its Naver and other than that I mean
it's Bing and wherever being has
penetration so if you're following best
practices for google
that should help you rank on bing that
doesn't necessarily help you rank on
Baidu and that's for China specific
reasons hmm in order to rank on by do
you actually need Chinese hosting and
the reason for that is is obviously
China has censorship and Baidu is
concern is that you're not if you're not
local they don't want to take
responsibility for your content if your
local you're already complying with laws
on what kind of content you can have
because your local mm-hmm so if you're
not local you're gonna see a huge
rankings hit your website will be
significantly slower obviously you know
getting behind the Chinese firewall yeah
so if you care about China there's a lot
of things you need to do it may be even
advisable for China again this is China
specific not Chinese language to have
like a separate Chinese domain because
to have that Chinese domain you're again
you're complying with the laws onin
Baidu will drink you Korea's different
Korea has Naver as a search engine I
don't remember the breakdown of neighbor
versus Google right now but what Google
used to not be dominant in in Korea and
they've been increasing dominance
through their Trojan horse of Android so
Google is obviously very closely
partnered with Samsung and LG Korean
companies and as Korean users use these
products they use Google prior to that
neighbor which is it was search but it
was also sort of like an AOL where they
offered everything in the afternoon from
forums to chat to blogs and search there
again their ranking algorithm is very
different and sort of rudimentary when
it comes to Google so less Korea is a
specific target for you what China's is
a specific target Google is all you're
gonna need right okay so if you kind of
just like optimize your Google strategy
dial that in you're gonna be in a really
good spot absolutely and so thinking
again internationally like GDP are just
happened what should people have in mind
and like why do you think SEO is
important in the context of GDP are so
I'm a middle of writing a blog post
about GDP are and the benefits for SEO I
think GDP ours when the greatest things
that has ever happened SEO in the last
five years for American companies for
everyone for everyone okay so one of the
requirements of GDP are is updating
privacy policies it's why everyone got
an email from everybody else they have
ever engaged with about a privacy policy
update privacy policies also have to be
very clearly defined and linked on
websites so now what you have is one
page
privacy policy that appears on every
single website or every single page of a
website to me that's the most amazing
way of cross-linking through an entire
website words in the past you may have
had a tough time of like how do we get
users from a homepage
over to this deeper page now you have
this deeper page which is linked to a
privacy policy and if you you know you
can involve a sitemap they need to make
sure that privacy policies there you
have one commonality between everything
every single page on a site privacy
policy mm-hmm so that's that's one
advantage the other big advantage is
that paid budgets are now going to take
a huge hit because of gdpr we've gone to
this nightmare scenario where you don't
know if you're paid budgets are working
because you can't track users until
users agree to be tracked so if you
reduce your paid budget we're gonna put
it right you're the only house you're
gonna go and put that as an organic and
you're gonna start ramping up for
organic efforts and then the other thing
that I think SEO really benefited from
this is paid has always sort of
cannibalized SEO because it's everywhere
mm-hmm you may have discovered a website
buy organic and then you got retargeted
and maybe you end up converting with
paid with the reduction of paid SEO
might actually get it to do like we're
gonna see that full funnel conversion
SEO all the way through SEO and is this
affected how you do like any SEO
practices not necessarily I mean the
other benefit to gdpr & SEO is it's one
of the few channels that works without
gdpr like without any opt-ins like
Facebook if you know I don't know that
the stats are out yet of people refusing
to use Facebook because they don't want
opt in through the privacy policy maybe
they're not in the platform anymore but
you don't need to agree to Google's
privacy policies and cookie rules in
order to use Google so you go in Google
you won't agree to anything any tracking
you're still now going to search and
find web sites okay great so if someone
wants to employ all these tactics who
should they think about hiring who
should be brought onto the team so the
people that I found to be the best at
SEO are incredibly creative and are very
curious and were able to develop a
hypothesis around what should work and
they're basing that on other things
they've seen things they've read
things that Google's talked about Google
as a whole guide on SEO best practices
they put out a guide on best practices
as well as a guide to their search
quality raters of how to evaluate
website so you can see what Google's
thinking so you want someone that can
take all that come up with ideas but
also is incredibly analytical so they
can understand what works and learn from
past performance of websites and measure
their own testing so how as say your say
your startup founder right like maybe
you have 10 employees or something like
that
how do you even evaluate the
applications you might get it's sort of
hard you want to look at someone like I
think someone that you know was
entrepreneurial in the past and
demonstrates that creativity but this is
something where I think you're the the
on-site in-person interview or phone
interviews we ask a lot of questions
it's really where you're going to flesh
out their creativity and that analytical
ability yeah looking at a resume I've
looked at many resumes if people have
done SEO and I discover they don't
really know anything about SEO they've
just done SEO when you you talk to
someone that would be good in this seat
and not doesn't even have to be as
someone that's ever done it before
you're asking them creative questions
like how would you solve this or like
what do you do if you woke up in the
morning and your organic traffic is
disappeared like where do you go first
how do you troubleshoot this issue and
just understand their ideas they'll make
mistakes everyone's going to make
mistakes but you want someone that you
know has that natural curiosity and
creativity along with the smarts to
really be successful in this actually
what is your answer to that that's a
great question your organic disappears
overnight what do you do that's happened
to me multiple times
okay so the first time it happened to me
I was working for a startup and I
remember the exact date
February 24th I don't remember the year
and it was the day Google rolled out the
Google Panda update so up until this
date which I think he was in 2010 the
best way of writing content was to write
as much of it as possible and come up
with every keyword and rank on
everything that you could think of and
these are the days of email where you
actually had guides on how to pour water
or how to boil
it's them crazy stuff anyhow and may
still exist so we had the set I was
working with and the company I was that
we had content for every possible
iteration we was an automotive review
site and we had every car we had every
review we had at every picture and we
lost 65 percent of our traffic one
morning so at the time I was measuring
rankings I no longer believe in ever
measuring keyword rankings late news we
discussed we're focusing on a user so
it's not just generic rankings started
with looking at our rankings what we'd
ranked on number three the day before we
were now at number eighty and so it
started with that then going into
analytics looking at the URLs that got
hit and then after that oh crap moment
it was it looks like this is a Google
penalty and it wasn't until I'd probably
say midday until the blog posts had been
out of like hey whoa
you know we've first put out the blog
post like we've you know we've gone out
and destroyed half the Internet who
changed the way things work man
okay that's and then what did you do to
fix it so we actually had to rip the
band-aid off
so we lost 65 percent of our traffic we
ripped off we took down tons of content
brought it down to like 80 to 90 percent
complete loss of traffic so we took it
intentionally took away organic traffic
and rebuilt up our high quality content
we architected everything we were going
to do we ultimately recovered so we
recover with a 20% gain on what we had
in the past hmm and how long did that
take that took only six months we were
lucky that like we ripped the band-aid
off we were able to do it nowadays they
could happen a lot faster yeah at the
time we were waiting we were waiting for
Google to rerun that algorithm once they
reran it we were back in the good graces
now like things are more automated and
algorithmic where if you got hit by the
penalty one day you cleaned it up did
everything possible
maybe filed a reconsideration request
you can be back a couple weeks okay
that's not so bad
so so going back to the this person that
you're evaluating to be hard for your
company say you pick someone you think
they're good you hope they're good how
do you set metrics for success like how
do you set a goal and then how do you
measure it and how do you know if it's
working like
what should you be looking for and
really like how much time should you
give this person so if they're creative
they should be it should be coming up
with creative plans right away so coming
up with a strategy of how you're gonna
grow and they're also gonna require a
lot of investment yeah if they're coming
up with a strategy around content you
got to buy the content so that's the
first thing you're going to want to look
for is like what is our strategy how how
are we gonna grow how are we gonna
increase your SEO traffic or get SEO
traffic if we don't have any to begin
with mhm that's the first metric I'd say
within 90 days you want to have that
plan hmm moving forward you're gonna
measure against that plan like are we
getting traffic where we do we make any
mistakes and our forecasts and our
estimates and then again assessing your
creativity how quickly can they iterate
and pivot if they're wrong mm-hmm
so you're you're looking at the growth
and traffic like that's your primary
metric once the traffic starts coming in
put some goals in that if it's a
start-up you can have things like 100 to
200 percent growth if this is a existing
company with already has tons of organic
traffic maybe it's all more manageable
to have 10 to 20 percent but those are
your metrics you're gonna apply to this
person okay got you and then I would
look at traffic and dollars coming from
this channel and what you never ever
want to measure for anything related SEO
is rankings like how many page one or
how many position one rankings we have
because those aren't yours to have those
are yeah Google could change your mind
or your users could change their minds
and like that is the wrong way of
aligning your SEO efforts yeah I mean
that that's kind of true across the
board like all of these systems if you
engineer the employee incentives for
them to just game it that's what's going
to happen and if it's not directly tied
to your bottom line you're wasting
everyone's time
absolutely what about these two like so
you mentioned a href you mentioned
Google Analytics what are the other
tools people ought to be considering to
like you know say you brought this
employee on right like what do you need
to install the first day to ensure that
you're tracking all the right things so
tracking can really be done with age
rests can help you track keywords again
I'm not a fan of tracking keywords HRF
scan all
to help you track links so if you're
building links it's just a good way of
seeing what Google's recognized not
Google but like H refs and hopefully
Google recognizing it to Google search
console that's free the other piece is
the technical piece so as you're
building out a site or as your or if
you're working with an existing site you
need to use a crawler to try to imitate
how Google would actually crawl the site
so my favorite tool there is called
screaming frog SEO spider there's a
similar one that only works on Windows
called Xenu link sleuth okay so you're
using these tools to really crawl a site
and you can get back all of your SEO
metadata you can see all your redirects
you can see all your canonical links
which is pointing to duplicate content
you pick up all your image URLs find all
your JavaScript it's really just like
recognizing whole site that is relevant
for a small site but just an interesting
tool to have in your tool set the other
thing you can do with that tool is crawl
your competitors now I wouldn't
recommend crawling your competitors from
your company IP address because if the
competitor savvy they may see that show
up in their log files like hey why is
yeah this IP address tied to my
competitor now calling me and they
couldn't make them upset so yeah
chiggers use at your own risk okay but
this is a great technical tool to just
understand how sites are structured hmm
cool and what about if someone just
wants to get into SEO like where do they
where do they start what courses should
they take what would you do so no
courses to take really it's a creative
pursuit yeah you have to you know start
drawing art in order to be an artist
here but the way I learned this was I
was working for a company that would and
I was managing affiliates and at the
time and it might still be true the most
expensive adsense keyword and AdWords
keywords was mesothelioma the lung
cancer related to asbestos so I decided
to see like well I needed to write
content in order to get content matched
to this Adsense keyword so I decided to
write content related to mesothelioma
and see if I get ranked and that was
really my first SEO project and in the
process I wrote something about John
Edwards and I don't remember the
connection to at night this is when you
could still see all the keywords coming
in
I saw keywords coming in related to John
Edwards and like well for I write more
content on this maybe I'll get more
traffic and I did so like that's where
you start you start with like an idea
maybe it's a personal blog maybe it's
something you're passionate about
create content get the traffic in and
learn from it and they you know if that
makes you excited to try more then this
is something for you if this is like
well this is taking too long and this is
really boring and I'd much rather be
like a Instagram influencer
awesome and well thank you so much for
coming in if if someone wants to reach
out to you and learn more how can they
connect I like LinkedIn a lot I respond
to all my LinkedIn messages and you know
I've done a decent job of making sure I
can be found on LinkedIn man that's
great okay that's also rare and uh yeah
it sounds like effective strategy yeah
thank you alright thanks Ben
you